well there was a laugh-out-loud moment
this morning it's Joe Biden and his
presidential pitch on ABC's Good Morning
America actually there were several nice
lappers but I'm trying to restrain
myself here but check this out the
president has a model make America great
again do you have one
make America moral again make America
return to the essence of who we are the
dignity of the country the dignity of
people to changing our people with
dignity and this god-awful deliberate
division that's being taken to in order
to separating people to aggrandize his
own power interjecting there Joe Biden
is gonna make us moral again now is this
the same Joe Biden who was driven out of
the race for the presidency years ago
amid charges of plagiarism or is this
the same Catholic Joe who has evolved
away from his core teaching of his faith
remember Joe was once pro-life and even
voted for partial-birth abortion bans in
97 and 2003 but only when that ban was
upheld in 2007 by the Supreme Court
well Catholic Joe evolved a bit what
this Court did it took that decision and
it said it put a Trojan horse in to
through actually dishonest reasoning lay
the groundwork for undoing roe v wade
that's the danger of this decision not
to specific procedure but that but the
rationale offered to justify I think the
next step they're going to try to take
well several bishops have denied Biden
communion in their diocese owing to his
rabid abortion advocacy I don't even
know that until today and now he's
lecturing us on morality and what does
Biden to even mean by his morality
dignity of the country the dignity of
people cheating on people would think
that any more respect and dignity than I
did before this is about restoring
dignity
work Wow let's face it Biden and he's
kind of a fun person you say hi to him
I'm sure he's a nice guy but at age 76
he's coming across it's just kind of a
rambling doddering less cool version of
Obama and we know how much dignity he
believed those working class Americans
deserved Obama mean but now we're
supposed to believe that those bitter
clingers are going to look to ramblin
Joe to return their dignity I don't know
I'm not feeling that most Americans just
don't look to the government to deliver
their morality or their dignity I think
most people just want to be left alone
to live their lives in peace and maybe
have a few extra bucks in their pocket
the argument Biden's basically trying to
make here is I'm nicer than mean old
Trump so vote for me I think you could
call this the mayor Pete effect Biden
saw Pete Buda jej mouthing religious
platitudes while advocating some pretty
radical policies and he probably thought
hey I can literally do that better than
he can but the truth is this is a
candidate and a party and kind of a
tough spot here political reported this
the other day saying Dems sweat Trump's
economy we don't really have a robust
national message right now oh you think
if you listen carefully the 2020
Democrats are making the case that their
ideas are going to grow the economy
faster than Trump or lead the bigger
wage increases or even lower
unemployment numbers and Trump's numbers
instead they become the self-appointed
self anointed leaders of a new liberal
moral majority
he needs to restore that moral fabric
ripped apart I believe that this is a
moral issue I believe this is issue
again that is about it's it's a
reflection of our values I'm tired of
swear the world
amnesia we have well speaking of moral
amnesia the Democrats have forgotten
what they've shown America lately after
spending two years defaming President
Trump calling him a traitor all the rest
Democrats are proven wrong in the Muller
report about collusion and yet they
refuse to even apologize how is that
moral and on the issue of illegal
immigration come on Democrats are lying
to the American people about a
full-blown crisis at our southern border
Pelosi and company aren't gonna work
with Trump on the issue just because of
politics how was that moral well in a
state and local level things aren't
pretty either for Joe Biden's we're more
moral than Trump party we're all the
morally superior Democrats calling for
the resignation of Chicago prosecutor
Kim Fox tonight who allowed actor hate
crime hoaxer artist Jesse Smollett to
walk free or how about liberal Baltimore
Mayor Catherine Pugh on the brink of
resignation tonight
amid state and federal investigations of
her financial dealings must have missed
Jo's comments on her and morality is
just busting out all over
at the Virginia State House where the
Democrats have a sitting governor and
Attorney General both with black face
problems oh let's not forget mr.
morality himself the Democrat lieutenant
governor Justin Fairfax well I'll let
one of his accusers tell that story I
broke down into tears
because I feel guilty why do you feel
guilty it happened to her after it
happened to me had I had the strength or
the courage to say something that's hard
to watch but in the immediate aftermath
of these stories remember some Democrats
did urge the men to step aside but you
notice how quiet it's gotten lately if
it had been a Republican or any
Republican officials accused of similar
offenses Democrats would not have rested
until those men were driven out of
office but clearly the Democrats like
Joe bitter about Trump's roaring economy
they're desperate and they're clinging
to their morality narrative but there's
another problem they've also become the
party of infanticide it was governor
Ralph Northam a pediatric neurologist
who while not in blackface explained the
grisly process that he sought to expand
under his state laws if a mother is in
labor I can tell you exactly what would
happen the infant would be delivered the
infant would be kept comfortable the
infant would be resuscitated if that's
what the mother and the family desired
and then a discussion would ensue
between the physicians and the mother
then days later the New York Assembly
passed a bill legalizing infanticide and
decriminalizing late term abortions the
reaction the bill is passed
that my friends is a moral standing
ovation these people are the moral
exemplars the 21st century are you
kidding me
Democrats ought to get off their moral
high horses are they're gonna get bucked
right off for it is immoral to condemn
and judge a man who like all of us is
flawed but who gave up a really cushy
life to fight hard every day for
prosperity and security for all
Americans and he's done more for the
cause of life than any president in my
lifetime I work for Ronald Reagan this
record of trumps is stunning even with
all the wrenches that the Democrats have
tried to jam into his spokes so pull the
numerous planks out of your own eye Joe
before you start condemning others as
immoral for political gain and that's
the angle